>>> THIS MORNING, THE MEGA
MILLIONS JACKPOT STANDS AT JUS
OVER $1 MILLION AFTER NO WINNER
WAS ANNOUNCED OVERNIGHT.
PUT THE CEOs OF FAST FOOD CHAIN
RAISING CANE'S PURCHASED 50,000
LOTTERY TICKETS, ENOUGH FOR ALL
OF THEIR EMPLOYEES.
JOINING US NOW IS A.J. CAMARA.
LOOK, THOSE TICKETS DID NOT WIN,
SO ARE YOU GOING TO DO THIS ALL
OVER AGAIN?
>> OH, MAN, WE HAVE TO AGREE ON
IT.
TODAY IS NATIONAL CHICKEN FINGER
DAY.
TODAY IS OUR HOLIDAY.
SO WE ARE IN CELEBRATION MODE
ALREADY.
NOBODY WON.
AND WE THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
US.
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT ALL OVER
AGAIN.
AT LEAST WE HAVE A HEAD START.
IT TAKES ABOUT EIGHT HOURS TO
PRINT THOSE TICKETS.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GET A HEAD
START TODAY AND GET THEM
PRINTED.
>> FIRST OF ALL, EVERY DAY IS
NATIONAL CHICKEN FINGER DAY AS
FAR AS I'M CONCERNED.
YOU LOST.
LET'S LAY IT OUT THERE.
YOU SPENT $100,000 ON TICKETS
AND YOU LOST AND YOU'RE GOING TO
DO IT AGAIN?
WHY NOT GIVE THE MONEY, GIVE
$200,000 TO YOUR EMPLOYEES?
>> YOU KNOW, WE ACTUALLY GAVE
OVER $200 MILLION IN INCREASES
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
LOOK, THIS IS REALLY MORE THAN
ABOUT MONEY.
THIS IS ABOUT, LIKE, HAVING FUN,
ET CETERA.
BY THE WAY, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
50,000 CREW MEMBERS WE DID WIN.
IT IS ABOUT JUST UNDER $10,000
FOR A CREW MEMBER, WHICH DOESN'T
MAKE A MATERIAL DIFFERENCE IN
TERMS OF IF WE RAISE WAGES TO BE
HONEST.
SO, $100,000 IS NOT GOING TO GO
A LONG WAY WITH 50,000 CREW
MEMBERS IF WE GIVE -- THIS IS US
TAKING CARE OF EACH OTHER,
STANDING BY EACH OTHER AS A
FAMILY TOGETHER.
SO, YEAH, I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
DO IT AGAIN.
I THINK THIS IS GOOD, THOUGH.
>> FRIDAY IS IT.
>> YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO
BE -- THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE GOING
TO ANNOUNCE THE WINNER AND YOU
THINK IT IS GUYGOING TO BE ONE
YOUR TICKET, A.J.?
>> SO, BRIANNA, JOEY CHESTNUT
BEHIND ME, HE'S NOT WITH ME,
HE'S GOING TO SET CANE'S RECORD
FOR EATING THE MOST CHICKEN
FINGERS TODAY LIVE FROM VEGAS
RESTAURANT.
WE FEEL GOOD ABOUT SETTING
RECORDS AND BREAKING SOME THINGS
THIS WEEKEND.
FINGERS CROSSED.
I THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
FRIDAY.
>> CHICKEN FINGERS CROSSED.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
GOOD LUCK.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
GOOD LUCK TO ME.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US.
>> THANK YOU!
I'M GOING TO BUY YOU ALL SOME
TICKETS TOO.
>> HEY, ALL RIGHT.
>> I DON'T WANT TO BE THE GUY
WHO HAS TO CHECK EVERY ONE OF
THE TICKETS TO FIGURE OUT IF
THEY WON.
>> EXACTLY.